welcome to this video playing the risk
junkie here played him before all right
the tango tango geography Knight c3
let's see what he's playing on uh-huh
Bishop before some actually the idea
don't my dad this is just them giving me
a good center okay yeah you can you can
play this just like a king's indian
should I go Queen d2 mmm yeah I can do
that there's a similar line with rook e8
yeah but I play this is with a 3
understand I can just move up here and
the neverland has a 3 plate and the next
remove is not better or him if I've just
be five cam can try to yeah sort of clay
4 p-5 trying to open lines which is of
course not do not correct but you're
already in desperate mode here otherwise
you're just getting getting mowed over
IM let's see 95 or Bishop g5 it's
probably both good 95 is a temple
sending the King back to G aid
yeah let's not spend too much time this
is the main issue with this is that he
might gather you get something on non
time because I spent too much time
position wise it sir it's terrible okay
should I go yeah probably spend the
smooth okay PMD 594 who don't want that
probably just take ok so after if I
capture that he's always got night c4 so
I better better retreat this and keep f4
as an idea and the bishop on e2 also
helps with h4h wife I've got some attack
attacking ideas as well ok he's two
times on your form but I have pushed f3
at the end so I don't know if I really
need to play Bishop f3 now ami yeah once
it's it's a good move just just
protected and I've got h4 h5 you
only dangerous 24 25 yard on the clock
and allow some syntactic which can
happen of course we came still some time
until there's a real threat coming
yeah counterplay ideas will most likely
be on b2 with the bishop on g7 all this
on a to some way to go to a 294 yep ok
this is at first threatening here so I'm
needs to react to that my question is
should i play b-52 simply open up the
position we take it cannot take because
c6 is saying if it takes f3 I can take
f6 of the society this is actually
instantly winning Bishop f3 I take on f6
maybe this was working before even no
not really I'm tightening f7 no this is
the the reason why this is winning f3 is
still hanging with to take with the
night check of seven so bit much check
yeah needs to take with the rook and
then I can simply take on okay I thought
you needed to take with the rook
the question is what what is the best
way to punish this now can even just
play Bishop deform or take here I can
take on c3 but this is just just
completely completely gone he takes
Queen D for threatening okay Jade so
it's made probably you can just ignore
this Bishop the knight on c3 protects a
two and this is the only weakness yeah
whoop you want check
yeah this is made up Queen a jade 195
patterns it's very very hopeless I want
now letting the clock run down and
wasting our time no check check so it's
not a maid least I don't see it which is
probably check not too worried me check
I but Ruby 7am this is made check check
night f7 made or queen of seven made
black resins gaddis opening is not
playable and this way I think it's at
least a very very risky I mean okay he's
the risk junkie but still here white
also has this move and after a three but
I can't play like that I just want to
show that this this way it's very
similar but white has spent the move on
a three in the game he played usually
you go Bishop before him he played the
six and then we asked the same position
but i have spent i have saved to move on
a 3 & a 3 it's not only a move lost in a
way but also we clean off the queenside
so if you have played a three you are
much less likely to cast a long and here
i even win a tempo here and then i can
castle castle long and this is already
dangerous I don't know g 4g 5s is coming
quickly until he's already in
desperation mode here with b5 check yeah
that this is now I'm probably a position
that white should win with precise play
but ok it's blitz yeah Bishop c4 was
also strong of course I didn't really
think about that that's bad okay when
these clips this keeps up keep the edge
computer things night takes aged five
years okay for black you have the kind
of movie don't really consider at least
I didn't consider it yeah Bishop's III
mmm yeah that's true you five was
probably the best yeah but this is a bit
messy so I probably missed plated
somehow yeah be should not playing
Bishop c4 systems it's just a really
stupid here this is just wrong he needs
to play a passive move now and the
bishop is no one up there the bishop is
also nicely placed on b3m for instance
if you place at one point 9 p-6 i can
just go to be 3 and the bishop is
attacking and defending at the same time
so this is just wrong and now i just
need to play normal move like like this
one and five getting getting at the king
yeah this is much better so night h5 was
the way to go and hear ya even h6
winning but this is this is terrible
black will explode iam alright thanks
for watching